the Prime Minister but Mr Speaker I know
the whole house will want to join me in
recording that after 10 tumultuous years
this is your last Prime Minister's
Questions and as befits a distinguished
former Wimbledon competitor you have sat
up there in your high chair and not just
as an umpire ruthlessly adjudicating on
the finer points of parliamentary
procedure with your trademark Tony
Montana scowl and mr. speaker not just
as a commentator offering your own
opinions on the rallies you are watching
sometimes a survey can sometimes kindly
but above all as a player in your own
right peppering every part of the
chamber with your own thoughts and
opinions like some tennis ball machines
I'm uncontrollable tennis ball machine
misters began delivering a series of
literally unplayable unreturnable
formerly unreturnable volleys and
smashes and although we may disagree
about some of the legislative
innovations that you have failed
there is no diet in my mind that you
have been a great servant of this
Parliament and of this House of Commons
Thank You mr. speaker I hope you will
indulge me one moment while I say a word
about you I'm sure you will
I want to thank you mr.speaker for the
way that you've used your speakership in
the decade-long tenure you've had you've
done so much to reform this House of
Commons and our democracy is the
stronger for the way that you've done it
you have preserved for 10 years you've
given real power to backbenchers vastly
expanded the use of urgent questions
which has been overwhelmingly popular
with all government ministers and opened
up the number of emergency debates which
is even more popular with even more
government ministers and in the
traditions of the great speaker lens
than others you've stood up for
Parliament when it has to be stood up
for I think we thank you for that
because you've also carried that message
internationally as well in the role of
parliamentary democracy and Parliament's
holding government's to account and as
we hope to form a government in the
future we hope to be held to account by
Parliament as well
Thank You mr. speaker I won't have never
known this place without you here and I
think it will be it well it's going to
be different it's a delight to see your
children here watching today because I
know that while you have a
responsibility to Parliament that you
take your responsibilities as a parent
incredibly seriously also we proceed
with a number of statements that need to
be made I would like to thank the Prime
Minister and colleagues for their kind
and generous personal remarks which are
greatly appreciated
I want to thank staff of mine past and
present who have given up their time to
be here today for the last Prime
Minister's question the BI chair all of
them are people who've worked with me
for a significant period of time we've
had fantastic relations and a terrific
bond and I hugely appreciate the fact
that they've bothered to turn up on this
occasion and in particular again I want
to thank my wife Savi and our three
children Oliver Freddie and Jemima for
the support stoicism and fortitude which
they've displayed through thick and thin
over the last decade I'll never forget
it and I'll always be grateful for it
Hey
you